today on the matt walsh show throwback
edition the hottest new trend on social
media right now is multiple personality
disorder lots of people especially kids
are pretending that they suffer from
this debilitating mental illness how did
this trend come about and why we'll talk
about that today also aaron rodgers has
clearly earned the mvp title this year
in the nfl but some sports writers say
that he shouldn't be eligible because
he's not vaccinated plus pope francis
condemns couples who have pets instead
of kids
proving again that even a broken pope is
right every once in a while and women at
the university of pennsylvania consider
boycotting in protest of the dude who
was allowed to uh to play on the swim
team they consider it they consider
boycotting just consider it finally in
our daily cancellation i will once and
for all and finally cancel superhero
movies all of them they're all canceled
we'll do that today on the matt wall
show
[Music]
well i feel like i finally made it as a
podcast uh host because we have an ad
from birch gold birch gold is the latest
sponsor in the matt wall show very
excited about that and listen right now
inflation is at 40 year highs and it's
here to stay
inflation rates are higher than the
interest rates on treasury bonds so with
every day that passes the government
owes less on its mountain of debt now
imagine if your mortgage had a negative
interest rate
would you be in a hurry to pay it off
probably not
so
your pain is their gain
protect your savings now hedge against
inflation with gold from birch gold
because the government is sabotaging the
value of the us dollar birch gold will
help you convert an eligible ira or 401k
into an ira backed by real gold so
that's that's peace of mind
and you've got real wealth there you've
got something tangible something real
with all the inflation happening right
now this is what you need to do and
that's why i am a birch gold customer
with thousands of satisfied customers
and an eight plus rating with the better
business bureau you can trust birch gold
to protect your savings text walsh to
989898
that's 98 98 98 to get a free info kit
on holding gold in a tax sheltered
account then call burch to protect your
hard earned savings text walsh again to
989898 to get your free info kit now
well welcome to the show today we're
just at the beginning of what's supposed
to be a major winter storm here in
nashville and by major winter storm i
mean like um you know four or five
inches or something but four or five
inches counts as a major storm around
these parts especially because of the
apocalyptic panic that grips hold of
everybody on the roadways as soon as one
single flake falls from the sky the
flake doesn't have to doesn't have to
fall from the sky actually i mean the
drivers around here if they see a flake
of of dandruff fall from their own heads
while they're driving they'll still
freak out and plunge right into the
nearest ditch what all that means is
that i can't get on the roads right now
because i value my life and so instead
of going to my normal studio i am back
in my original studio i'm getting in
touch with my roots today
back in the car
talking to my dashboard once again
thoroughly confusing my neighbor who
just walked out of his house
hey and was
obviously confused about what's
happening here now i could have recorded
in
my house which i'm sitting right next to
right now in the driveway but the
problem is that all four of my kids are
home right now and the only way to keep
them quiet for an hour would be to
i don't know lock them in some sort of
soundproof box in the attic but
cps generally frowns upon that kind of
parenting strategy and so uh this is
what we're doing also it just it just
felt right it feels right to be here
again
in the car so um
we start with this
if a lab in china has proven to be a
factory for viral contagions
um you know in the world
then the internet social media in
particular and especially tik tok is a
factory for a different kind of
contagion social contagion
destructive and degrading and uh you
know behaviors and lifestyle choices
concepts ideas can go from fringe to
trendy to mainstream quite literally
overnight right what was unusual one
minute might be ubiquitous the next and
people especially young people can get
caught in the current and drowned before
they even notice that their shoes are
wet here is perhaps
the latest example
and maybe the strangest
also a very instructive example
over on tick tock there is apparently an
intense interest in multiple personality
disorder or did dissociative identity
disorder is what they call it now
hashtags related to this topic have
millions
of entries i mean hundreds of millions
of entries that's how that's how much
interest is that's how popular it is and
many of them are from users claiming to
have did themselves the trend has grown
large enough that even good morning
america has noticed and they did a
report on it a couple of days ago watch
this
now to the rise in teens on tick-tock
who are self-diagnosing themselves with
rare mental health disorders that they
probably don't have after watching
videos on the social platform it's a
story we first saw in the wall street
journal and ariel reshef joins us with
more on this ariel good morning
good morning to you matt mary those
videos have been viewed hundreds of
millions of times and while experts say
this may be elevating a conversation
about mental health self-diagnosis can
be a dangerous slippery slope
the id typically occurs between the ages
of six and nine this morning experts
warning about what they call a troubling
trend on tick tock that could leave some
teens believing they have a serious
mental disorder
host with the hashtag disassociative
identity disorder and borderline
personality disorder viewed hundreds of
millions of times some of those videos
listing possible signs to look out for
and encouraging viewers to self-evaluate
right so now in these videos and again
there are many of them
the alleged multiple personality
sufferer will will usually refer to
themselves as the system
that's how these people refer to they
are the system
and the system is the word they use to
describe the whole collective of
personalities that they have in their
heads and then each individual
personality is called an altar
and they will then usually introduce
each alter in their videos each
personality and sometimes put on a
different voice for each one but that
requires a certain amount of talent that
most these people don't have um and so
most of the videos are kind of like this
one watch
hi my name's becca i'm the host of the
system
hi i'm bella i don't really know what
role i have in the system because i am a
new alter so
hello my name is
what's up it's jamie i'm the primary
protector of the system
we took our meds a while ago so i'm
groggy
hi my name is vega i am the sexual
protector of the system hey i'm kai i am
a trauma holder and gatekeeper for the
system i work very closely with another
alter nick
who is an internal uh caretaker he does
not really front
so you see that's how multiple
personality disorder works apparently um
all of the personalities are aware of
each other and and they work together
you know they hold meetings and
conferences they send memos back and
forth and emails and everything
this is what happens i guess when you
have 14 personalities and they're all
boring as hell
though some members of the alleged did
community on tik-tok they do try to keep
things a little bit more interesting so
here's a guy whose personalities are are
more antagonistic towards one another
which makes it more interesting watch
hey everyone it's asher the best alter
this is dan the life of somebody that
has dissociative identity disorder let's
go
hi everyone it's annie and i'm going to
be in charge of cleaning today that
means i'm going to be out i'm going to
be listening to my music and i get a
nice couple hours just to myself this is
really nice because i tried to get some
time out yesterday and i couldn't
and since i'm going to be out for a
little bit i changed into my clothes
this is my necklace and this is a shirt
somebody sent me everybody it's alex and
he got jalapeno in her eye and then
switched out immediately so i had to
switch in and now i'm having to deal
with the pain so thank you annie hi
everybody it's april this is the before
shot
and this is an aftershock this is why
i'm in control of what the body looks
like the boys would make it look
homeless
now
the impression of did that you get from
videos uh like this is that a person
with this disorder has sort of a cohort
of little gnomes or gremlins living in
his skull driving him around fighting
for control of the steering wheel and
that's
most of the videos are like this and and
they've been extremely effective
in convincing other people on the site
mostly kids that they too can have
multiple personalities the problem of
course
there are a lot of problems uh one of
them is that is that this is how split
personalities work in movies and tv
shows not in real life there was a
best-selling book called sybil back in
the 70s i think they made a movie uh
about the book as well
and that that's that's the one that
first popularized this concept of
multiple personality disorder before
that
um it it existed as a clinical concept
but it wasn't it wasn't in the
mainstream the way that it is now and in
that book the patient sybil real name
shirley mason
has a condition that works kind of like
what you see in the tick tock videos
kind of like what you see in the movies
what was that m night shyamalan movie
split where the guy has 15 different
personalities and some of them are
serial killers and some of them aren't
um and so
shirley mason sybil had something sort
of like that
problem though the book was based on a
lie the whole thing was a hoax it was a
fraud
even so it's cemented into the minds of
the american public and and people
um this idea and people have been
convincing themselves that they suffer
from this fake version of the illness
ever since
now of course i say fake version of the
illness as if there's a real version
i don't think there is now this is very
much a live debate in the psychiatric
field right now
some so-called mental health experts
will argue that did exists but it's very
different from the cinematic portrayals
and others will say that the whole thing
is a category error that it doesn't
exist at all it's an invention of the
psychiatric field itself
now according to this argument which i
find extremely persuasive
there's only a very very very small
number of patients who would even
potentially qualify for this diagnosis
and then among that small group a
certain portion of them are simply
faking it
that's the problem with with this mental
with a lot of mental illnesses in fact
is it is that um despite what what
you're often told or what you what you
might think with a lot of these
illnesses
uh they have not located the illness in
the physical brain itself
because if they had they wouldn't call a
mental unless they would call it a brain
disease or an iron neurological
condition
but those are distinct categories
so if they're calling a mental illness
it means that they have not
um
with any with any
they have certainly not conclusively
located the illness within the brain and
if you haven't located the illness
physically
then it's really just theoretical
whether it physically exists or not
um
and so that's that's that's another idea
about multiple personality disorder that
it doesn't exist
that it's only a very very small group
of people who potentially would even
qualify for it many of them are faking
it and then there's also another portion
that have been conv they're not faking
it intentionally they've just been
convinced through cultural and
therapeutic influences that they have
the disorder when they really don't so
it becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy
now at any rate it certainly can be said
that
those who believe in the existence of
legitimate multiple personality disorder
have never come close to actually
proving that it exists
all they can do is produce examples of
people who claim to have it which is far
from the sort of proof that they would
really need
is it even possible for a single mind to
contain multiple distinct personalities
distinct minds within itself which are
separate from each other and not aware
of what the other is thinking
how does that even work
is it possible for a mind to be
compartmentalized in that way
it's an extraordinary concept which
requires extraordinary evidence to prove
and none of that evidence has been
provided
but that's all somewhat academic right
whether split personalities exists or
not we can hopefully all agree that uh
10 million people on tick tock didn't
all suddenly start suffering from the
illness all at the same time
this trend is without a doubt a result
of both self-delusion
and deliberate fraud
and often kind of a mix of the two
maybe it begins as a deliberate fraud
and then people actually
succeed in convincing themselves that
they really have it
um i i used to be very good at this kind
of thing when i was a kid when i would
pretend that i was sick so i didn't have
to go to school
and then by late at late morning i'd
actually start feeling sick because i
was so good at acting the part and i
think something like that happens
sometimes with these mental illnesses
now the more interesting and important
question
is why exactly
so many people would want to convince
the world and themselves that they
suffer from what would be a debilitating
mental illness
i think there are a few answers to that
one is the most obvious point
that the mentally ill are a victim class
victimhood is is power in our culture as
we know the more victim labels you can
claim the more power the more social
credit you accrue also too
many people lack anything approaching a
real identity or a real personality
mostly because they've been staring at
screens every waking moment of their
lives and letting the internet do all
their thinking for them
and
they have almost no internal dialogue
they have no almost no internal life at
all
um and because of this
you know they tend to adopt a quantity
over quality approach to personality
usually this will come in the form of
adopting different pronouns different
sex and gender identities but this
latest thing is even better because it
allows them to literally take on more
than one personality
all of the personalities are dull and
uninteresting
but they but what they lack in substance
they make up for in sheer numbers i
guess
three related to this
mental illness in general is especially
trendy in its own right largely for the
reasons covered by the first two points
and four this all stems from our
fundamentally disjointed and essentially
superstitious view of the self
so we see the self
ourselves
the self generally
not as a continuous holistic coherent
thing
but as an arbitrary amalgamation
of our desires and our hopes and our
preferences in any given moment
we're constantly in the process of
uncreating and recreating ourselves
our ourself of five minutes ago
doesn't necessarily bear any relation to
our self of right now and our self of
right now
may be entirely different from the self
that takes the field tomorrow
we see ourselves
in this culture today as these kinds of
um
shape-shifting changelings
lacking any concrete overriding identity
and according to this view of things
really we all have dissociative identity
disorder
because it's easy to dissociate from an
identity when you don't really have one
at all to begin with
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know me i love talking about
mortgages and a lower mortgage rate can
make quite a difference on your budget
it's true i mean you could be saving
hundreds of dollars a month simply by
refinancing to one of these incredibly
low rates think about how about how much
that could help
uh if you were able to do that then pick
up the phone and call american financing
and do it now before rates get any
higher i mean you cannot miss out on
what's available right now especially
since there's no cost to get started
there's no risk you might as well try
you'll get a free no obligation mortgage
review from a salary based mortgage
consultant who will walk you through
custom loan options they'll find every
way possible to save you up to a
thousand dollars a month
without resetting your terms okay you
can choose any term ten years and over
and you have the potential to skip two
mortgage payments as well so don't put
your refi off any longer now is the time
to do it call 866 569 4711 that's
866-569-4711-866-569-4711 or visit
americanfinancing.net
america financing nmls 182 334 nmls
consumeraccess.org
all right i got to hurry up and get
through this show so um i can go out and
uh i can go out there out just outside
my my car here and hit the slopes
and by that i mean sled down the hill in
the backyard in my kid's five dollar
plastic saucer sled you know i mentioned
this on the show yesterday and um that i
like to you know go sliding when it's
when when it snows
and lots of people seem surprised and
sort of take it aback and maybe slightly
disturbed by this image of me going
sledding and enjoying myself
because that's not really on brand i
mean sledding is not on brand and
enjoying myself is not on brand
enjoyment is not part of my brand but i
want to clarify uh just to try to put an
end to the pr crisis that has
happened because of this rumor that i
enjoy myself
my kids know that this is not about
enjoyment okay
my kids know that that i i always have
to use the sleds first
and i have to play with any cool toys
that they get i have to play with them
first
and i have to eat all their candy and
you know and i do that because it's it's
about making sure that they're safe it's
about making sure that these things are
safe for them so this is a sacrifice on
my part that i take on
like for example the other day my son
took uh his allowance money
and he used it to buy a remote control
car for himself
a cheap one okay believe me we don't we
don't give these kids much in the way of
allowance so he had to save for about
four years to buy a 12 toy but anyway he
brought it home and um i of course had
to play with it first
just just to make sure that it you know
that it was safe that it didn't explode
or you know go haywire and start bumping
into people's shins or whatever
and um and then when i started chasing
the dog around the kitchen with a remote
control car that was all about safety it
was just making sure that it's safe it's
all safety
and my kids are so used to this now that
every time they get a new toy or they
have a new piece of candy or whatever
and and i come into the room they always
ask me timidly they say daddy can you
please not check if it's safe
can we just use it ourselves
but what do you mean you want me to
forsake
my fatherly duty
no children no this hurts me more than
it hurts you believe me
but i have to do what i have to do
you'll understand when you're older okay
this this is what love is all about
all right so
uh first of all we'll start here today
is january 6th
you've probably heard by now
the most important of days
the most solemn of days
the holiest the most tragic the most
significant
it's a day when almost every show will
be talking about the fact that today is
today
and what today means and what it what it
means uh what it meant a year ago and
what it means today and what it will
mean next year
both right and left shows we'll be
talking about january 6th on january 6th
and the fact that it is january 6th
which is why i will not say anything
else about it moving on um second aaron
rodgers is the
odds-on favorite to win nvp this year in
the nfl because statistically he's had a
great season
and uh he's playing well his team is
playing well but some sports writers
have decided that he doesn't deserve to
be mvp because he isn't vaccinated
chicago sports writer hub archus was on
a local radio show yesterday in chicago
where he explained why he didn't vote
for rogers
and again it's got nothing to do with
play on the field it's all about his
medical choices watch
do you have an mvp vote this year hub i
do yeah i'm one of the ap there's 50 of
us who vote and i am one of us
and are you
did you reveal that you're not voting
for aaron rodgers is that correct
i did yeah i mean i've been pretty
consistent about that all year i don't
think you can be the biggest jerk in the
league and punish your your team and
your organization your fan base the way
he did and be the most valuable player
has he been the most valuable on the
field yeah you could make that argument
but i don't think he is clearly that
much more valuable than jonathan taylor
or uh or cooper cup or maybe even tom
brady and and so from where i sit the
rest of it is why he's not going to be
my choice do i think he's going to win
it probably you know a lot of the voters
don't don't approach it the same way
that i do others do who i've spoken to
but one of the ways we get to keep being
voters is we're not allowed to say who
we are voting for until after the award
has been announced i'm probably pushing
the envelope by saying who i'm not
voting for um but we're not really
supposed to reveal our votes
okay so we're gonna
decide mvp based on personal medical
decisions
that um aaron rodgers has made and as as
we've gone over a million times you know
the argument that well it's not really
personal because it affects other people
because you can affect other people if
you don't get vaccinated
um that argument
that was weak
when a year ago when these vaccines
first came out now it's not just weak
it's it it's moot it's a moot point you
can't make that argument anymore you can
make it but you're not going to be taken
seriously
because vaccinated or not everyone's
spreading the virus
so the the your whole argument
about how
it's
reckless you know to not get vaccinated
you're not just being reckless with your
own health but you're putting other
people in danger that's that is the
argument that all this stuff is based on
the mandates everything
it's all based on the idea that you're
putting other people in danger if you
don't get vaccinated
well that never really made sense
because if the vaccines prevent
transmission
then
as long as you're vaccinated you have
nothing to worry about
but now we know they don't
and so everyone's in the same boat but
you know part of this is also just um
this is also
when we look at the politicization
politicization of sports
um
and
when they're lecturing about vaccines or
whatever
you know part of this is the fact that a
lot of these sports writers are died in
the wool lefties so we know that
but also i think at a deeper level
psychologically
they want their job to be a lot more
important than it really is
i think at a certain level they they
realize and they
they acknowledge
that
they do what they do for a living is
really kind of stupid and frivolous and
i say that as someone who enjoys sports
i like watching sports and i'll listen
to
sports analysts drone on sometimes
but i even when i'm sitting there and
i'm watching sports analysts i'm
listening to sports analysts argue about
who's the mvp or uh whatever you know
who who played the best game yesterday
i'm listening to these arguments i still
recognize that this is very very stupid
really
it's one thing to watch the sport but
the discussion around it
it's really kind of dumb and if this is
what you do for a living every single
day
then i think some of these people that's
that's that's right look if this is what
you do for a living you talk about
sports
and um
and you embrace that like this is what i
do it's it's it's entertainment i'm i'm
an entertainer
and uh and that's fine then i say well
it's that's perfectly noble that's
perfectly fine
okay i
i do a podcast for a living here i am in
my car right now how important can i be
so as long as you embrace that that's
what it is it's just entertainment
sports is entertainment and if you're a
sports writer then you also in effect
are an entertainer
because that's all that this is all
about
um
[Music]
but i think that there are some sports
writers and sports analysts who who want
to be more important than that
and when you think about the discussion
what this guy what's this guy's name
again
hub archus he's brought on to talk about
mvp what is that
the most let's have it let's have a
discussion and um let's debate for
months on end who the most valuable
player is
which is a totally arbitrary doesn't
even make really any sense the most
valuable player to his own team
well each team has their own most
valuable player so who's the most
valuablest of all the valuable players
what does that mean
why does it matter
who who exactly put you in charge of
declaring that who cares what you
declare
it's all arbitrary but they want to find
some deeper social significance to what
they're doing uh because of their own
ego their own narcissism their own
vanity they don't want to admit that hey
we're just entertainers this is all
entertainment that's all it is and so i
think that's what a lot of this
politicization is all about okay
meanwhile whoopi goldberg has been gone
from the view uh because she got coveted
even though she's been vaccinated three
times
and she came out of you yesterday to
talk about how shocked she is
that she did everything right
and she still got covered
i left
a couple weeks ago just before the break
because
uh somebody i had been around tested
positive for carotid virus so i left so
i've been gone a long time i feel and i
was all excited and and uh you know they
have to test us and so they sent people
to test me and uh they tested me and it
was like oh no you're not you're not
coming back
without sending anybody to your house
you have corona
and it was like wait what
what it was it was a shock because you
know i'm triple faxed i've been anywhere
i've done anything but that's the that's
the thing about the omicron you just
don't know where it is you don't know
where it is who's got it who's passing
it so you know it's one of those things
where you think i've done everything i
was supposed to do yeah it doesn't it
doesn't um it doesn't stop omicron and
that's the problem with a variant
because it gets stronger and does
different stuff to you so you know
unless everybody gets vaccinated this is
what we're going to be facing
uh okay first of all it's really cold in
this in this car i didn't really think
about that it's about 20 degrees outside
and i can't have the car on because
that would make
there'd be a distracting noise so i'm
just sitting here freezing anyway um
whoopi goldberg is is really shocked and
appalled and almost sort of offended
by the universe
that it's put her in this position
she says i've done i did everything
right and i still got it
well yeah now
maybe connect the dots on that
you've spent years doing you have
adjusted your life you have your life
has revolved around this for years
you've been wearing masks you've been
you've been injecting everything they
tell you to inject every time big pharma
comes out with another another
another vial of
of drugs and they say inject this into
your body you say oh yep here's my arm
you you present it dutifully to be
injected with it and you do all of that
and you've secluded yourself from your
family all of that and yet you still got
it
okay so you've you've realized that
now connect the next stop just what what
does that mean
does that mean that um well now you've
got to double down
and inject yourself with even more stuff
and where
five masks now instead of four
and uh isolate yourself even more
no it means that it's futile
that there's no reason to do it
that you're gonna get sick everyone's
gonna get sick and then you're good and
then most likely you're gonna be fine
and then you're gonna go back to living
your life
and down the road from now maybe a year
from now maybe two years maybe five
years you'll probably get sick again
with covid
and then eventually you'll get sick with
something probably not coveted that will
kill you
and that will be it
so live your life okay and then there's
uh there's this one more thing on covet
here is user
that darn chat on tick tock giving her
reflections on the last two years and uh
she is by far not alone i think
in feeling this way unfortunately listen
i usually have no problem finding words
for things but lately i just i'm at a
loss
every single person i talk to is
drowning and for me the day-to-day it's
fine it's not fine but it's fine i'm
getting through it and i feel like i've
been in a state of grief now for what
two years grief that my kid will never
go to a story time at the library my
kids haven't had birthday parties my
grandparents have never met my
two-year-old there's grief around what
i've had to face
through difficult conversations with
loved ones learning that there is a
drastic difference between my values and
theirs grief and having to face that we
are only cogs in a machine that despite
the fact when capitalism failed early
pandemic and so many people stepped up
to care for each other the systems that
be want to continue to make survival an
individual effort i feel grief over
isolation i feel grief that my kids have
to grow up with a mom in survival mode
and morning routine and access to dreams
because it just feels like there's no
end every day as a parent
is assessing risk
and trying to figure out what fat to
trim
yeah it is really cold in here
can you see my breath yet
it's very cold in this car uh anyway
what was she talking about yeah yeah
she this is unfortunately she says she
feels all this grief and everything and
um these are all things that she's that
she has done to herself these are all
choices that she has made for no good
reason whatsoever she has decided to
destroy her life and that's that's her
own decision but unfortunately she has
kids
and it's not their decision and she's
destroying their life as well but what
we have to understand unfortunately is
that
you know
there's no rescuing these people
um i mean that woman there there's
there's her brain is broken
i don't think there's any way to rescue
her now
as i've been talking about this this
part of what this has been about from
the beginning
is that people are
people like this woman here
who had been living in this kind of
psychological bubble
and had insulated
themselves in their luxury
had been insulated insulated themselves
from from the reality of the human
condition
and from the reality of their own
mortality
finally face forced to to confront the
reality of human mortality they just in
in that confrontation it something
snapped in their heads
and they weren't able to face it
because that's all this has been about
for someone someone like her she's young
she appears to be healthy
covet has posed almost no threat to her
at all this entire time
but
it is a threat
i mean it's out there
it could kill you
and um and there are many other things
that could kill you too but this is the
but this is being shoved down your
throat every second of the day
and so it just it made her realize her
along with millions of other people very
early on it was like this moment for
them where they they realize oh my gosh
there's
i'm a human being
i'm i'm mortal i could die
i am totally
vulnerable and naked and exposed
in my in in the human condition
i am this frail pathetic little thing
here for only a temporary period of time
and everything out there could kill me
at any second
now some some people who are a bit more
reflective have always known that
and have lived every day with that
awareness and we've learned how to just
cope with it
but she never did she never learned how
to cope with it and all of this came on
all at once
and
it broke her and so many others and i'm
not sure that there's any rescuing them
now psychologically
and that's that's a great tragedy
because again
if we can't rescue them
it means that's very difficult to rescue
their kids
all right uh moving on
this from the new york post says pope
francis 85 had some choice words pope
francis 85 years old by the way that's
not his name pope francis 85.
um pope francis had some choice words
for the childless at the vatican on
wednesday in remarks to a general
audience the catholic church had called
out couples who have chosen not to have
children
and opted to have pets instead
the pope said quote today we see a form
of selfishness we see that some people
do not want to have a child
sometimes they have one and that's it
but they have dogs and cats to take the
place of the children
he suggested that couples who can't bear
children should look into adoption the
cost of which can tally up to seventy
thousand dollars the pope went on went
on how many children in the world are
waiting for someone to take care of them
it's a risk yes having a child is always
a risk either naturally or by adoption
but it is riskier not to have them it is
riskier to deny fatherhood or to deny
motherhood be it real or spiritual
um
well it's not very often that i get to
say that i agree with pope francis about
something as i said even a book even a
broken pope is right well he's certainly
not right twice a day but
maybe twice a decade he's right about
something and so this is one of those
times
um
man it's it almost sounds like pope
francis has been listening to the matt
wells show maybe he listens to my
podcast i don't know
because this is something you've heard
me rant and rave about many times
look and
we need to to clarify for the people who
struggle with this for some reason
when we talk about this
nobody is saying
that you have some kind of moral failing
if you're not able to have kids
obviously
um
nobody's saying that it's a moral
failing to have pets
well
i would almost go that far but i'm not
going to go that far especially because
unfortunately we have pets
that's so that's that's not the point
the point is when a choice is made
by couples
you know who who could be parents
when a choice is made to be the parent
of
of animals rather than human beings
that's when it becomes a moral failing
that is selfishness
that is you giving up on the human
species
and in fact as pope francis points out
if you're a couple and um and you can't
have kids again not your fault
but that's when you're you you are
uh prime candidates to go adopt any of
the any of the many children out there
who are languishing in the adoption
system or in foster homes
now adoption isn't this isn't for
everyone necessarily i mean that's
something you got to reflect about and
pray about but but uh
but
you know if you if you can't have kids
rather than going out and adopting 15
dogs or something
it's certainly worth considering whether
one of these children right now who have
to think about
kids who are suffering in this way
it's it's unthinkable
now fortunately um
young very young children babies
there's a wait list two miles long for
babies who are up for adoption they're
not going to be in the system for very
long
but a child who's a little bit older six
or seven years old and ends up in the
system ends up in a foster home
uh ends up in the adoption system
[Music]
you know there's just there aren't that
many candidates out there waiting to
adopt kids that age and so that's a
great thing that you could do to become
a parent of one of those children
something to consider
but mainly i think what we're talking
about here is the choice again
to forgo
being an actual parent of human beings
and instead you're gonna be a parent of
animals
um i i do think that there's a fair
amount of selfishness that comes into
this
you know the
why is it that people love having pets
and when they talk when you hear people
say that uh
they prefer dogs over people
you know you know you know how much that
annoys me when i hear people say that
especially because i know why they're
saying it
why do they prefer dogs over people well
because dogs are not nearly as
challenging as people
dogs don't don't require
the sacrifice of you the same way
the same way people do
a dog is just going to sit there he's
going to be very happy to see you all
the time he has very little he has he
has very little of his of his own
identity you know so he's not going to
impose his own identity on you in that
way
[Music]
he is there for you
um
and his his life revolves around you
and
that's and that's why people love dogs
that much
because it makes them feel better about
themselves because when you get a dog
that dog's life is going to revolve
entirely around you
doesn't make it bad to have a dog but
that is why people like dogs
human beings are different
you know a human being they're going to
be they're going to have their own
identity
and their life is not going to revolve
entirely around you
as very young children that that tends
to be the way it goes but as they get
older they start to develop their own
identity
and um
that's when there's even more of a
sacrifice required of you but it also
means that the love in that relationship
is much more meaningful
because it's also this is this is also a
choice made by both people
so it's all self-serving i think okay um
this is from the daily wire
several women on the university of
pennsylvania swim team considered
boycotting their final home meet in
protest of transgender teammate leah
thomas's physical advantages and
dominance the women ultimately decided
not to go through with the boycott the
daily mail reported fearing that they
would be banned from the ivy league
championship the women also discussed
participating in a false start a source
close to the team told the daily mail
they've been ignored by both pen and the
ncaa and there's a feeling among some of
the girls that they should make some
sort of statement seize the opportunity
while they have a spotlight on them to
make their feelings about the issue
known
so
they were they were thinking about
staging a protest they were thinking
about boycotting they were thinking
about refusing to take part in all of
this
um but then ultimately they decided
otherwise well i have to say it's good
that they were thinking about it
but we need to graduate beyond the point
of simply thinking about it and actually
doing
so i i understand why they didn't go
through with it
because they're worried about the
consequences to their
career they're worried about
um
what will happen they're worried about
being punished by the ivy league or
whatever so so i get that
but at a certain point
we need to be willing
to make sacrifices
in order to take a stand for what's
right to take a stand for basic sanity
and truth and moral decency
if we're ruling that out
if we're ruling courage out
and we're saying well we want to solve
all these problems in a way that will
not require courage
well then forget it pack it in
forget it
none of these problems will
civilization is done
abandon all hope at that point
if we're ruling out courage because yeah
it would it would require courage
it's it's not fair to these girls that
they were put in this position
it's not fair that that um
refusing to participate in the charade
of a swim meet where there's a guy
competing against girls it's not fair
that that could um
create significant blowback for them
none of that is fair but but but that's
that's life that that's what they're
faced with
that's the reality it shouldn't be that
way but it is
and so if you want to help make sure
that it's not going to be that way for
the next group
then you need to stand up and do the
right thing not just think about it do
it
yes it it
it
it may cause problems for you
it may hurt your career it may damage
your reputation
but there are times in life when that's
when you're called upon to make those
kinds of sacrifices
this is one of those times
i i am at the point of victim blaming
with this i really am
you know the the people
the women who
choose
to participate
in these kinds of events when there's
men involved
the parents
who don't pull their kids out
all the people who go along with it i
mean i i think they all
deserve some of the blame now
because there's something you could do
about it and you're not doing it
if all of these girls got together and
said we are not doing this we're not
gonna participate in this this is a
farce everyone knows that it's a farce
everyone knows that it's wrong
and we're not gonna play this game
if every girl did that or even half of
them
then this problem goes away
time to step up time to step up ladies
all right uh from the new york post it
says the pizza chain little caesars is
bumping the price of its famous hot and
ready pizza above five dollars for the
first time in a quarter century
the price of the promotional pie which
was first introduced in 1997
is increasing by eleven percent to five
dollars and fifty five cents so
inflation claims another victim
um but i do have to say
this is pretty bad because five dollars
is already way overpriced
for what they're selling
little caesar's pizza taste wise is
indistinguishable from the box it comes
in
so it's actually kind of a nice deal
because it's it's a two for one
you can eat the pizza and then eat the
cardboard box that it comes in and
they're like the same thing they taste
the same
little caesar pizza is a is a pizza box
with um
hot ketchup smeared across and a little
bit of mozzarella cheese that's that's
the whole recipe
little caesars is so bad that it makes
dominos seem edible by comparison that's
how bad it is
and now it's going to be 5.55
thanks a lot joe biden
let's get down to the comment section
[Music]
oh man if i i can't feel my toes at this
point so we got to hurry up through this
uh jesse miller says i could totally
imagine matt out in the snow taking
sledding super seriously well i do take
it seriously because again it's all
about safety for my kids
and um it's a very serious business
philip says i've been in law enforcement
since 1991 and i must say something if
any of the capital police officers who
are present on january 6th are
traumatized by that event and they
should probably seek another career
because they're not cut out to be in law
enforcement
uh
yeah i think i think what you're saying
is valid especially because
we have not heard um
any of the officers
who were
subjected to the blm riots complaining
about their trauma
von rohnken says the cry circle
tradition was absolutely hilarious
hilarious
this is
my pain and suffering and that of my
family
and you find that hilarious
these open vulnerable moments that we
have as a family where we sit around in
this in a circle
and weep
well i'm glad to know that that our pain
is funny to you
you're banned from the show
yes i can still ban you from the show
even as i'm sitting in my car
um
[Music]
and let's see james says matt i'm a
mortgage loan officer seeing how
interested in my business you are and
how much you truly appreciate it makes
me happier than i can express well yeah
mortgages are one of my great passions
in life um just like all of all of our
advertisers all of our sponsors
you know i'm passionate i think i think
it really comes through in the way that
i read the advertisements
constantine says
armed robbery should unironically carry
the death penalty
i think there's a much better argument
that can be made for the the death
penalty for all armed robbers than than
misdemeanor
as what it is in manhattan now it's a
misdemeanor
um
[Music]
and
oh there was a good one that i got i
gotta read
oh here it is here's johnny says hey
matt i think you'll find this story
interesting
so yesterday i went into a department
store while sporting my brand new sweet
baby gang t-shirt that i got for
christmas this year
when it was my turn to check out i
approached the counter with my things as
the cashier began scanning he soon took
notice of my shirt and asked me with a
smile so what does your shirt mean
anyway as i started to open my mouth to
explain another store worker close by
interrupted while laughing and goes
yeah is that like a daycare center or
something
how dare he
how dare he
i was a little bit offended but i just
wanted to move on with my day so i
simply said back to him no it's actually
more of an inside joke at that moment
the cashier asked me so what's the joke
at this point i was pretty ticked off i
then adjusted my posture began to arch
my shoulders back to assert my dominance
uh nate clo
made close eye contact with both of them
and proudly said aloud the first rule of
sweet baby gang as nobody talks about
sweet baby gang
they both laughed loudly and the
co-worker began to walk away while
shaking his head saying
omfg man wow
the cashier still chuckling a bit then
asked seriously dude
i looked him stone cold in the face
stared right into his eyes and sternly
replied yes
he then seemed taken aback and even
froze for a second before responding to
me he then leaned over the counter
towards me and whispered in my ear
how can i become a member
i have to say normally when someone
tells me ahead of time how i'm going to
respond to a story oh you'll like this
oh you'll think this is funny oh you'll
find this interesting normally when they
do that i'll react the opposite way just
out of spite because i don't like being
told what to do but in this case yeah i
did indeed find that very interesting um
that was a far more interesting story
than anything in any marvel movie for
example
and this just shows the beauty of the
sweet baby gang i think
because it confuses people
and it makes them very uncomfortable
and it causes really awkward
conversations
but then in the end in the midst of the
chaos their defenses are broken down and
that's when we grab them you know that's
when we take hold of them
and before they before they know it
they're in the cold too
so masterfully done johnny
my good and faithful servant
tomorrow is a huge day for the daily
wire and the lawsuit against the buying
administration's tyrannical vaccine
mandates why is that because it's the
day the supreme court will convene to
hear arguments on the legality and
constitutionality of the biden's
bind administration's descent into
all-out medical tyranny that's why we
need to make sure that we have as many
signatures as we possibly can on our do
not comply petition um and we've already
got one million we want to add more go
to
dot com dailywire.com do not goodbyes
dailywire.com do not comply and sign
that petition now now let's get to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
you know over the last couple of days
i've spoken about my experience watching
the latest spider-man film over
christmas break um as a father i'm again
called upon to make many harrowing
sacrifices for my children and taking
them to see spider-man was just the
latest in fact
many of my fatherly sacrifices have to
do with
enduring awful movies you know and it's
a burden that i carry with with uh with
silent dignity i think
well maybe not silent and not dignity
because i complain about it all the time
but still the point is that i watched
spider-man
i didn't like it to say the least and
during the comment section of the show
um i have briefly made my case against
it
but this conversation has provoked anger
from the audience and even dissension
within the ranks at the daily wire my
own producers sean and mckenna are
marvel apologists themselves and i'm
told by a source that when i was making
fun of spider-man yesterday on the show
the people in the control room
were shaking their heads scornfully
because they didn't approve of what i
was saying
things have gotten very very tense
we just hired a new intern for the show
uh this week and i had to send her to my
car yesterday to start my car for me in
case somebody had planted a bomb or
something because that's that's how
serious this is
but
one thing you know about me is that when
people get upset about something that i
say
that just encourages me to say it again
louder and longer
i have as you know the maturity of a
four-year-old which means that i should
actually be the target audience for
marvel movies but they still don't
resonate with me because although i have
the maturity of a toddler
i still have the brain of an adult
which unfortunately precludes me from
enjoying anything that marvel has to
offer and so today we're moving beyond
just the latest spider-man movie
and instead we're going to expand the
scope of our inquiry and finally once
and for all
cancel marvel itself all marvel movies
they're all cancelled indeed all
superhero movies of all types are
cancelled and i'll explain why
the first problem with superhero movies
is that they're all exactly the same
and they exist primarily to sell
merchandise
these films are basically 95-minute
mattel commercials only with less plot
and worse acting
now i'm being generous when i say less
plot because that implies the basic
existence of some kind of plot
now superhero movies in the 90s were
merely light on plot
superhero movies these days are entirely
plot less
that's because of the advent of
franchise filmmaking and world building
and that's turned every movie into a
setup for the next movie which itself is
a setup for the next one on and on into
the infinite abyss
nothing can ever really happen there
could be no substantial progress no
final resolution
no real character development
no actual triumph or defeat
because it's always just setting it up
for the next one each installment none
of these installments exist on their own
none of them stand on their own that's
films
they just exist because they got to set
up the next one and the next one and the
next one
you may as well pay 18 to watch thor
play solitaire for two hours or
something i mean it's it's it's the same
in the end
ten thousand years from now as as the
next installment of spider-man is
released to the screens that we'll all
have permanently implanted in our
eyeballs at that point i think
philosophers will be debating
whether these superhero franchises even
had a beginning at all
they may well conclude that there was no
prime mover no first cause in the marvel
and dc universe
these movies always existed
telling the exact same stories with the
exact same actors
since before the beginning of time
itself
now don't get me wrong
um
i don't hate superhero movies as a
concept
i have nothing against a fanciful tale
about a man in a rubber suit fighting
bad guys
bad guys who
through approximately 20 million story
arcs still have not thought to simply
walk up to their nemesis and shoot him
directly in the face
now i'm no expert on the mythology of
marvel or dc but i'm pretty sure a
bullet to the face would dispatch almost
all of the heroes in all of the
universes
i know except for superman and a few
others but the rest i mean spider-man
just walk up to him and shoot him in the
head
and that's that's it that's the end of
that
but these are issues with story
and superhero movies don't exist to tell
stories
they don't exist because someone really
felt passionate about telling another
story about aquaman beating up a tiger
shark or whatever they exist to
perpetuate a brand
now
all filmmakers want to make money
every movie is supposed to make money
though lots of them don't
but for these superhero franchises
that's the be-all and end-all that's the
alpha and omega that's the only point
the films are not inventions of
storytellers but of corporate focus
groups
they are things made simply to exploit a
market now it's a very large market and
a profitable one
and it's one that i would sell my soul
and exploit also if i could make a
billion dollars doing it but that's all
this is about
now when i talk about this i'm often
accused of taking the stories too
seriously
but that's exactly the problem i don't
take them seriously because i can't i
take them as seriously as i take like a
geico commercial
and the problem is that the writers
don't take the story seriously either
which is why they're at the point now of
throwing everything into the mix just to
keep the franchise going super powers
magic miraculous technology throw it all
in
whatever is needed in each successive
moment to propel it to the next moment
and each moment is inherently
meaningless because it only exists to
set up the next one
and then at the end you can erase
everybody's memory and uh and do it all
over again in the next movie
the writers have no respect for the
audience
they aren't writers at all they're
glorified content aggregators
all of these marvel scripts they should
be writing listicles for buzzfeed
but instead they're making marvel movies
because that's what the movies really
are they're kind of just like click bait
content
this is this is in the era of content
creation that's what these movies are
they're simply content
it's uh it's marvel saying well here's
more cut here's two here's two and a
half hours you [ __ ] sit down and and
have some of this
they shovel more slop into the mouths of
an ever eager and compliant public
always ready to eat whatever is served
to them
that's why i don't just dislike these
movies i reject them on principle i hate
everything they stand for
and i urge you to free yourself of their
clutches
i urge you to join me in saying to comic
book movies
you are cancelled
and
my feet are officially numb now so i'm
gonna stop the show and go inside and
warm up
uh before i die of hypothermia right on
camera which would be which one speaking
of content would be interesting content
that's gonna do it for us today thanks
for watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pavel
ledowski the show is edited by robbie
dantzler our audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is done by
cherokee heart and our production
coordinator is mckenna waters matt wall
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 22.
john bickley here daley wire
editor-in-chief
wake up every morning with our new show
morning wire
on today's episode the chicago teachers
union votes to shut down in-person
classes
mayo clinic fires 700 employees over its
vaccine mandate
and new studies find that fewer
americans identify as religious
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire